you
so thank you everybody for coming
tonight my name is Peter Barca I'm a
member of the 2 Sigma Labs team and I
have a great interest in software
engineering I want to understand how we
build software I want to come to do it
better and I'm particularly interested
in using automation to do that better
one of the area's I'm really interested
in is technical debt so technical debt
is the long-term cost that we incur for
short-term goals there were all these
changes that we know we should make to
our code bases but we put off because we
have more urgent things that are that
have to be done but if we don't
eventually deal with this technical debt
it encouraged interest and we have to
pay that infest all an increased
development costs down the road it makes
it harder for us to add to be so
recently I've been involved in a project
into Sigma that I spirited to use of
automation to help decrease our
technical debt so we actually build a
framework of tools that let us run
automated process want all of our code
and apply refactorings to them test them
submit them for coming here and then
into the system so that's one of the
reasons that I really want this paper
why do I want this big on first reading
you might not see anything really grab a
groundbreaking here but I kept coming
back to the paper then we're some really
some things in it that really got me the
authors are demonstrating a practical
solution to a practical problem and I
really like the way that they test and
evaluate their solution so what is the
problem they're sewing it's the question
of how can we keep our old coded up to
date with current best practices what's
the practical solution three backward
and completely automated refactoring so
the reason that they want to make this
refactoring is because of java java 8
included a group of features that were
called Project lambda during their
development phase project lambda is
really exciting and it's probably one of
the biggest changes ever to happen to
each other language one of the chief
complaints people have about Java is the
verbosity there's so much boilerplate
you have to say you have to repeat the
type name to say look the variables
going to be
say it again you allocate that variable
when you're doing intraclass you have to
say the name of the class you have to
say the name of the method you're
overriding you have to add an annotation
reminding yourself that you're
overriding a method if you mean like six
curly braces to close your whole thing
up so lambdas make that bar simple and
it actually continues a trend that's
been going for a while I think Java
inherited or was born with this
verbosity and they've been trying to
move away from it in Java 5 we got the
enhanced for loop that made it far
easier to get right over collections in
a raise in Java 7 we got a diamond
operator but doesn't actually offer you
a halt but the governor it's the thing
that means that you don't have to say
that your hash set of strings is
actually a half set of strings with an
alligator you can just say this half
step of strings in the hash set you can
rip what goes in it so Jonathan lambdas
take this way but they're really just
anonymous inner classes that implement a
single method now this sounds like a bit
of a cheat at first it's actually a
really powerful way to do it because job
already had anonymous inner classes this
is just a new syntax for something that
already have so we can't land us we get
most of the power that you have
in a functional language but we can
retrofit them into the language anywhere
where you were already using an
anonymous inner class you can now use a
lambda the syntax just got barson
so the other thing that lambda is
allowed and what are the main motivating
factors for doing this work add into the
language is the new stream wider giant
this dream library is based on the the
operations that you may be used to in
functional languages are ready for
dealing with lists they give you the
ability to do things like map and filter
and reduce the things that you're
probably used to if you programmed
enclosure or Scala or hostile but Java
programmers haven't been able to use
until that the composed stream
operations that they allowed so the most
room operations that they allow are more
semantically explicit than preform loops
programmer has to explicitly say they
encourage the programmer to think about
these steps a chain will define filter
Map Reduce operations instead of the 343
form for loop you get these well-defined
escapes it's easier to understand but
the biggest selling point for the
streams library is parallel ism
converting these
means the chain of streams to be
parallel to the coach well it started to
burning a stream of chains to be Pamela
is just a one more change you don't have
to introduce hundreds of lines of thread
come to manager it just happens for free
so much like an example as an example of
replacing and imperative for loop java 7
style with a stream style functional
loop in Java 8 so you can see that we
had me for loop here it iterates over a
list of rules and call some on some
mutating function on in the new style
the code looks very very similar except
we're using a stream and a lot and
lambda so you can see here instead of
curly brackets we've got round brackets
lamb ducks on a block expression oh you
cannot curly brackets in your language
as well but we're calling stream to say
we want the screaming inter based and
then we call it for each which lends us
operate on each thing in the list so
this is the particularly great
motivation it actually looks like I had
to write a little bit more code to do
the same thing five wonderful I'm
paralyzed that this is the java 7 code
to do this in parallel and I cheated a
little bit here I cut some corners this
isn't the proper lane paralyzer this is
wait and this is far better than what
you have to do it in Java five so we
allocate a thread pool I have to guess
how many threats i'm going to use i'm
just a poor if i have 32 CPUs on my
machine don't be idle and I have to wait
while terminate I just do that in the
loop I don't think this will never not
finish Suns going to look for one day
finish there's no other way to do it and
it might broken interruptedexception um
someone of the room who knows how to
correctly handled interruptedexception
in Java raise their hand a couple people
wake of how hardly thinking baby yeah
interruptedexception Jake man almost
nobody knows what to do with that friend
an exception deprecated businessman also
sees that in part that's the scary than
one thread that is it can be drawn from
anywhere backstage yeah that was a fat
again you it's talking from dying
the world trend basically deprecated
okay so let's meet the Java 7 here's the
job anyway very nice notice not stream
it's a parallel straight that's all you
have to do jvm takes are the class
libraries take care of the rest of it
for you so this is a really good
motivation for using the streaming
interface even if you don't believe any
of the other advantages of using the
functional style program you've got to
be you got to believe with the silk
better way right parallel code so one of
the benefits of strings and rounds if I
haven't already persuaded using lambie's
resulting code is simpler to read it's
simple reasonable and it's far far
simpler paralyzed parallelism is
critical more slot continues to march
forward but it got turned on its side a
few years ago chips aren't getting any
faster they're just getting quiet we're
getting more and more cars on the same
chip they're actually running a little
bit slower than they used to so the only
way that we can make our programs faster
is to paralyze and this finally makes it
to do that still not easy but easier but
why wouldn't we do there are costs
changing all over code takes a lot of
time and effort there are a lot for loop
in Java programmers I know there's also
risk of error there are several problems
you could that you can introduce what we
do this if you're not careful you might
change the semantics of the program in
Subway's or you might end up calling
your lung function a if you may also
just end up getting frustrated because
you don't understand all the rules like
just scoping but what if a tool did it
for you then the cost is zero risk of
error is 0 and you still get all been
immense so what does this April new
modem of terrorizing frugal ABR they
decide to implement a tool that
automatically transforms Java programs
to first of all convert anonymous inner
classes too long to lambda expressions
and to convert our loops that iterate
over collections to functional
operations use lambda expressions so
converting anonymous glasses this is
actually be really easy one you can see
that the benefit here is just Clara this
doesn't give us the parallelism
or anything but this is the old way of
doing that we tell the threat that we
wanted want to create with runnable
intelligence a runnable and wealth the
only one method in run I have to tell if
i'm going to let me run and I override
it and I just want to print something at
the Java 8 we can use a lambda chi lo
looks at it and says well there's only
one functional interface that you can
use to construct a threat so I'm going
to guess that's a run and there's only
one that didn't run that you can
override so that's probably wrong that
you're implementing you could just
express that as lambda it also just type
inferencing of the variables again from
the arguments to that matter so this is
a game with a easy simplification become
reduces and lines of code that you have
to sift through to find the important
things it's a straight over
transformation this one's pretty easy to
do I actually kind of get the feeling
thing that if you wanted to do the
library word factory one is well do this
ones that threw it in it handles a bunch
of special cases that will be annoying
to do my hand the scoping rules for
lambdas are slightly different than
it has to be a particular type of
interface so there was a handful of
interfaces that you might think you
could use this lab this but you can't
because I actually implement two methods
not just one I can't refer to this or
super you can't use recursion I'm not
sure I ever seen anybody use recursion
in an amount and as possible it is
illegal not your members though and it
figures out the syntax evening for the
type inferencing why don't is you can
don't always have to put in the types
sometimes you do and the tool is able to
figure out whether you do or not so
that's the easy one this is a really
juicy 11 thats excite debris or loops
into function of streams of functional
operations the tool is able to take free
form for orders and using a conservative
arresting it can convert many of them
into changes three operations now it's
your Ristic so there is something that
can't be right and there are also some
for operations that simply cannot be
converted without completely change into
code but it turns out that they can
actually transform a huge percentage
surprisingly effectively so there's an
example of a transformation that they
make this is actually transformed using
their tool in netbeans their tools are
not part of the official
it's release so up here is my original
example I'm summing up all the positive
numbers in a list of doubles the tool
detects that I filtering a filtering to
only get the positive ones and then it
sees plus equals and figures that was a
lot like a production some converts it
to reduce operation the codes down more
explicit and trivially paralyzed so I
guess that you're able to convert for
loops into chains of composable
streaming operations they support the
most common streaming operations and the
math filter reduce that you're probably
used to if you dealt with functional
languages
sorry duck and they also handle any
match and none match which are just
predicate operations to test once in the
set duties have to go inside the filter
map etc like can be assigned them to a
runnable a runnable a equals to lambda
and them oh yeah I'm real name them yes
if you wish it although in that case I
believe you need to provide some extra
type information because the type of
fruit single worker but this syntax does
allow you to to do that so the question
was can you use lambdas outside of the
context that are just arriving here and
the answer is yes with a little bit more
syntax because there's not enough
information with the times ok so
converting hold how do they do this so
the first thing I have to do is filter
out some of the for loops that they
absolutely can't deal with if your for
loop has a break they give up on that's
essentially it go to it's really hard to
refer to a functional time I've actually
thought about this a bit and I think
that there are some special cases where
break could be converted but they're not
handling
right now they don't do anything if you
have they also ignored if you have in
return except with a special case of
returning true with us we're able to
have a bad huh but so I said they can't
handle breaks but they can handle
continues they point out the continued
is actually just an inverted yep so they
rewrite the continues two gifts and then
continue on with the transformation so
once the new tvs reps they look to all
the apps in the gifts get turned into
filters and every other expression gets
to put it into a map now you can't quite
do that but it's a good place to start
next they go through and look for Matt
that actually interdependencies that
they can't just pass through to each
other and they merge those ones back
together to make larger Maps so we
optimistically start up and divide it up
as much as they can and then start
putting it back together and once
they've converted it to all these
filters and the minimum number style
minimum number of correct your house
they have to look at what the terminal
operations so one of the differences
streaming interface and a for loop is
that the streaming live library allows
you drafted lazy strings when you do a
filter now filter isn't actually applied
until somebody who looks out for loops
on the other hand are imperative and
happens right now so they have to make
sure that the terminal operation in the
chain is an eager operation so that it
collapses the result so that can be a
for each if it has a mutating operation
at the end or it can be will reduce or
it can be one of the anymore any match
or no match so as I mentioned they use
the most fine-grained operations that
they can they believe that this gives
the programmer the most control over
parallelism should you decide to
paralyze it's also the most explicit
having more steps more small steps
seemed clearer to me as I mentioned the
last option chain must be eager and it's
going to repeat they do not
automatically paralyze it or what they
leave you with is something that you can
paralyze by adding one word after you've
looked at the code nature that's
actually safe to paralyze it which is a
far more complicated problem and the
complicated problem bear song
does it actually work well they tested
it on nine open source projects
consisting of over a million lines of
code with 4300 tests there refback ones
actually found 2700 opportunities in
that code they ran all the tests and
there were no fare box so that's a
pretty good level of confidence that
this is correct but how well does it
look so this is something I'm really
love about the way with a purpose this
is a problem that they're trapped in
this problem they are trying to do
something that human does that we're
trying to make a computer do it the best
way to test that is to compare it to
humans I love that they're comparing
this to humans and that's something we
should do more of in computer science
this is great if we what computers to do
human tasks we need to compare them to
humans so how do they crowded image and
humans try to do the same task and then
they compare it to what the computer
game and they used to measures that they
borrowed from the field of information
retrieval so these were members I am her
people but it's pretty neat I think this
is a clever way to do it so the metrics
they used are called precision and
recall precision is the measure of
quality this is how well is the task
before in this case it's a tax recall is
Emmanuel quantity it says did it do it
in the right places did it find all the
opportunities so in addition to these
metrics they also did some quantitative
metrics they met our lines of code which
is actually a pretty coarse metric and
easy to easy to manipulate and if their
transformation converts all my four
looks at a one long line they'll be able
to prove that they produce fewer lines
of code but so what an expensive huge
lines let they also measure the change
in the size of the abstract syntax tree
that's a lot harder to fake it is a much
more sensible measure of complexity if
the tree has fewer nodes it's easier for
me to parse in my head and easier for me
to understand as a program oh well here
the results they found precision recall
for the first refactoring the anonymous
inner classes was 100% they found every
single opportunity that a human did and
they did it just as well as a human for
the second refactoring the poor loops
which is the hard one I think ottoman
ninety percent
human blood and again ninety percent
precision mr. yes man for some recall
and ninety percent precision which means
that ninety percent of the cases they
broke it down into the same the same
number of fine steps that human a human
only found a more detailed way to break
it down and the cases so that's pretty
good the other really interesting thing
they found was that there was very
little clustering this means this is
that for only two point three loops at
2.5 anonymous inner classes change
profile changes were really spread out
so doing this by hand would be
particularly tedious you have to look at
nearly every file new project and this
is not something you can do with a
search and replace it requires a deep
knowledge of the programs of the syntax
of program and understanding of the
language you cannot express that regular
expression
additionally both the lines of coke
measure and syntax tree measure show
that the resulting program was simple
and that's a really good bet
so they mentioned paper a couple of
opportunities they met to a better job
and I've been thinking about this and I
think there's actually more I think that
with a bit of an extra work this could
be hugely improved to do far better than
the forty six percent of loop that they
were able to divert I think we could
actually much more than for one thing
they didn't handle cases where the poor
loop was been waiting over the rain they
only have on cases where it was in
collection i SPECT sound emailed to the
author and he doesn't quite remember why
i was young i suspect that the java
dates that was in flux when they were
doing this work and the options for
iterating over raised change several
times java 8 is under development so
they didn't think they could do it but
it turns out that there are AP is just
really livable raised in the final spec
forty-one percent of the cases that they
couldn't remember where because it was a
ray of the world if we can have that
they can handle raised there would be a
huge number of additional opportunities
i think they can also handle returns of
more than just blends common pattern
i've seen is to iterate over
action and we'll turn on the first
element matches a particular criteria
you can do that with filter and fine
first they can also convert nested for
loops to use blackout which we expose
even more opportunities for parallelism
there are certain kinds of certain times
when reduces actually has a count of
because you're counting how many things
match your criteria so you can do that
with a belt remember views but you can
also just do it with the filter and
count so I think that they made a great
start and I think that it's possible to
be even further and do even better
so one of the lessons I want to take
away from this paper I think there are
three major lessons and these lessons
are what I love about this paper
refactorings help us manage technical
down our old code for these only if it's
part of an active project still being
developed should be held to the same
quality standards as a new code and
should conform to current best practices
three factors like that error-prone
tedious but with some thought we teach
computers to do these in you know what
it might be a bit more work to teach the
computer to do it but I think
programmers computers is a lot more fun
to do repetitive tasks on computers are
gathered in community grow to do mine as
my tedious task then do it myself the
final lesson leader right this is the
researchers are duplicating a human task
of the computer the best way to evaluate
that is to test against humans I'd love
to see computer scientists testing
against humans other than the realm of
cubic human-computer interaction where
we're good I think that we can borrow a
lesson from psychology professors who
use their students as test subjects
there are lots and lots of computer
science
great test subject so an open the floor
to discussion but before I do I want to
ask the question from audience so first
in admission I love IDEs going to quite
ready little X i can use Emacs i use VI
well enough to save a file and exit you
better exit without saving the girl body
dr. gualla Lord is it cold you man sup I
love IDs and love that Eclipse knows all
about the structure of my program
helpings interact and lets me do these
complicated refactorings but i also want
to automate refactorings i want to take
them over to the of the IEP and bring
them to the command line so what is the
set of refactoring I'd like automate
these things what tools do people do
I've written some of my own using the
clips AST which is very powerful but
it's just the bare bones frame but you
need to do this there's it lets you
manipulate a syntax training which is
great but there's nothing else on top of
us want organized imports you have to
rank all yourself I've seen a project a
little disco I haven't tried it it looks
like it's headed in this area there's
another project from google called wheat
faster that does a very specialized form
of pattern-based refactoring looks like
a great too old but very specialized so
I want
somebody can tell me what they use I
want to know so yeah so young playing
map reduce complexity of amazing thing I
Bruce is it will run across an entire
focus as a MapReduce and gets equal
access to the ast of any sink in the
river so objective ccc+ and you can do
AST transformations and will remit the
code using plenum format is very clean
whatever cement language code and so you
can do distributed free factories using
that n clean tidy is a framework for
specifically doing this type of reactor
you for all the cases like the ones in
this presentation where you know the
origin or not and you know the target
format and you know the programmers
probably leave a lot so you want to run
across any type of submission into your
repository you just clean tidy rule and
run
actually sounds kind of similar to what
I'm would be closed AST it gives you the
same ability to manipulate java files
but i think what i'm looking for
something a bit Richard like inside
eclipse itself if you're writing
refactorings in the IDE you can make
these changes and you can add imports
and they'll automatically organized the
imports for you but these tools are
those tools things that are built on top
days to you all time to the IDE and I
want to run outside the idea but yeah
I'm the transformation for primer play
like client is fantastic and I will
definitely take a look at that for
manipulating sica which i also bought
off the screen logo cookie exhale you
know I'm going to get a panic
fine DX mu i dou upon us for Canadians
this is a very strange just leave your
language tonight okay i'll definitely
that yeah we compared the cliffs
interfaces to intelligence I have not
some I mitigate bias here why I used to
be an idea in Canada and the clips came
out of the lab where I work to your by
using batch mode yeah then there are
guys are available for a batch of my
bleep all right I the plug-in
architecture has like a headless mode oh
yeah i know some people build headless
mode 20 clubs when it's a total back
tailgate striper
I masjid too seriously college but I
mean I've heard a lot of good things
about it yeah every language sequence
was in everything first platform it's
beautiful the sugars are amazing this a
lot of plugins
factory is the audience if you make
something that tries to
cute there's there's there's a
the easier stuff possibly because it
also
so the biggest thing that eclipse is
missing is eclipsed does java analysis
at hawk they basically is writing their
own AST walker whereas IntelliJ has a
whole framework for attribute grammars
so you can write Java code that can do
lazy and incremental computational
analysis on asds for live analysis so
the clips does that all ad hoc and like
acknowledge a actually has like tools
from optimize that sort of analysis
correct it validated but it sounds
little bras so you don't answer my
question general discussion yeah so I
presume arrays are hard because you're
in control of how you get into the array
at you'd have to analyze body of the
loop to make sure that we don't mess
with the lead vessel as soon as you stop
doing that it's no longer a linear
transformation into the loop right so
you can some questions about a while
you're not dealing with ways and because
you can you can access a race
arbitrarily that's true but in Java pipe
introduce the enhanced for loop which
you can use to iterate over the way in
order and you actually don't even get me
index when use that that method so you
can't even write back into the array at
least not easily obviously say they
can't even do arrays with me Hans well I
can see why and how would you feel oh
yeah the arbitrary three claws for what
they they completely ignore but they
haven't
tool that they were older Liam that
converts classic for loops to enhanced
works so there's I think they felt there
was no point in duplicating that in this
work but yeah I agreed that you can do
arbitrarily complicated things with the
rice but you can also do really simple
things we're presuming that other tool
that you just mentioned then they would
have to analyze the lead body to make aw
show that the know exactly okay so they
don't really know how to make that
transformation okay and Anna so so
speaking single arbitrary complicated
horrible raised there is a framework
that is designed to identify how to
simplify that in kind of non
intersecting nested for loops called
Gimple and that does it does Luke
dependency if there's a loop iteration
dependency tracking by and so contract
with Hannibal nested array is figure out
how like it sort of it did it isn't
basis vector transform on your nested
loops but anyway you know having us you
could solve the nested complicated
with that I think as long as you're not
actually mutating the array while you're
while you're iterating over again it
shouldn't it should be fairly
straightforward Gimple actually handles
them you taking that every case too but
I think once you throw a mutation into
the into the mix you can't really loyal
as crazy as anyway how particularly
pelletizer right yeah so they give any
analysis of the impact on like the
garbage collector one time because it
seems like they're allocating a lot more
objects as a lot more iteration of this
yeah that's a good point so the extremes
interface definitely does allocate more
objects but they are very short-lived
objects that the charlatan sets they
will only live with the duration of that
function and they never escape the
function so assuming the JIT is doing
its job properly it is able if that's a
huge assumption in it should be able to
detect that these things don't escape
and simply stack allocated agreement
decompose whether or not actually
every case is really hard to say but
small shortly objects are generally
thought expensive they only live in the
nursery they get collected even if they
do escape from the staff they rarely
made to pass the nursery and don't have
a long-term impact on long lived on the
long live part the heat if your
application is really that sensitive to
garbage collection especially local
garbage collections you should be
considering a big real-time garbage
collector for not using the garbage
collected language this time from got
your garbage collectors yeah so you're
saying that i'm using the streams
framework you want to kind of break
things up into fine grain stats I those
seem to be some tension between this
tool sort of break set up as much as
possible than stuff to collapse them
you're giving intuition that parallelism
you don't want to collapse it too much
so azumi there's some heuristic of which
they decide this is the right balance or
so my understanding of what they're
doing is a break it off as much they
break it up about more than possible so
they break up every single operation
into a separate step and then they
detect which operations actually had
together because they're independent so
it's not a heuristic
which is a hard rule they break it up as
much as possible but no oh so they they
overshoot kid what happens here oh shoot
and then that in the reconsolidate where
they have to so I mega I'm lacking
intuition for why we want to break it up
as much as possible why would that
necessarily better for Carlos I have to
admit that I'm kind of taking the
authors on the word on this one I think
it just using more places to insert
paralyze the next operation breaks down
into more pieces which is in mrs. sarah
ruhl because there's a granularity the
pieces are too small common courtesy my
family so it's not he's confusing topic
I think it's basically 2 News yeah they
eventually did so that like you can like
do you mind how to insert parallel
operations and the way I showed you in
parallel is is kind of a shortcut you
can replace dream with parallel Street
but the other way to do it is actually
to insert a call to parallel somewhere
in the chain and I not quite sure what
the consequences are to bet on where you
choose to insert it is is what a laser
more periods needs more places of not
overpower you think that's a
synchronization step but every time you
do one of these simulations you have to
finish because I'll show you where the
criteria that you didn't get a bunch of
rows or three or four lines but when you
get like that back you're like Matt a
brunette do I want to paralyze matt d a
CMP so you in debt see any rabid Brenna
sees and you stick it where Carol
something all of those things but I
think it's wrong to think of a
synchronization point between steps
because the mouth isn't completely we
don't complete each each stage in the
chain before we start the next one we
wanted for each element because it sits
right streaming so it's kind of lazy
evaluation when you ask for the first
element we apply the map and the filter
and reduce and we don't
mouth filter reduce we don't do all the
maps and store the results remember we
never store the information results did
you have a question
yeah you're very early sightings is a
really mine an epic but it was the
reduced I was kind of surprised that
didn't in line the zero that it was
starting off with his double and there's
any way out on that and it seems kind of
strange they wouldn't do that I agree i
think it's just a i think that that the
tool could be further improved i
absolutely agree that should put the
zero right into the indian to be into
the column and then something i didn't
show her much a little bit they actually
inserted an unnecessary map step into
that example as well and i removed for
the sake of the example today they did a
map of b2b I'm a little bit suspicious
what ended up in netbeans isn't actually
quite what they implemented because it
seems to to be slightly worse than they
described it just not quite as good as
they described then continue cutting
into its candies continue
from label rights you can jump depends
correct yet it not that that is an
exclusionary criteria if you as a
continued with the label that's
essentially it going to this is not
about death with a curious request
remaining framework is there an
equivalent that's like closure reduced
which lets you do earlier nation of
string operations I'm not sufficiently
familiar with audio it is the idea that
you like you're reducing rapper turned I
reduce a distinguished type so as you
said I can say by a curator of Internet
reduced engine that just breaks out
growth so yeah I've been sufficiently
familiar with either a hyper closure or
the strings interface to say for sure
yeah yeah this is a bad trip buddy edge
they know there's like a site effectual
cancel or reporters not that I'm aware
of it was a rental
it's an estate that try to wrap the type
and you say the special flag of things
that you should immediately get rid of
when you jump out what sort of those
things I was like really are setting a
hassle the eyes whole transducer thing
application any early foundation so like
fine first sort of situations so but
other ones of life but they will reduce
so it's not just fine it's like while
you're reducing you like beside boot up
because did mom is that will sort of the
things of that fine first is a fine
person sufficient because any Japanese
builder and so if you had I would do
summer in your operation Jane produces
either run 100 to avoid an eager mapping
or Annie or filtering yeah i guess i can
imagine a case think you're reducing two
doubles if you eventually reduce to man
oh there may be no point in continuing
anyway i think it kind of examples table
i already take one right yeah i don't
know how you paralyzed that so that
might be one reason the thing wouldn't
do that so they actually the closure
actually does paralyze it as well
because yeah okay yeah yeah since the
first cut of doing screams so maybe John
the nine so after you make these
transformations does the code
compatible its previous tours that for
example the first transformation might
be equivalent and I'm this closer so
that work there right so the question is
when you make these changes does it
become incompatible with previous
versions of Java so I'm going to address
the two different transformation
separately the first is the anonymous of
the classes and the answer to that is
yes and no your resource code it is now
java 8 specific however the bytecode
should be unchanged so it will remain
compatible older versions of job with
the form transformation the answer is it
is incompatible completely incompatible
with previous versions of Java because
the streams library is not part of the
standard Java libraries a Java static so
you would be using classes that don't
exist is there
they're being various different ways
over the years to back for features from
from newer versions of Java to
conversions I'm not aware anyone has
done that it seems unlikely in this case
because you need a few teams java
decompiler and some accidents can have a
class libraries hi I haven't seen
anything like that but it's not
impossible
anybody else your questions yeah why
would anyone wanna my job so that's an
excellent question hopefully that's Java
actually wasn't invented language to
begin where they came in a boat and it
was we are running relatively quickly on
palm and we provided a direct access to
all the palm AAP is so we had a native
library you can book that you could call
the api's and as long as you weren't
doing any any deep number crunching or
something most your time respect in the
libraries anyway and you got the
advantage of being able to use the Java
libraries which was pretty nice because
if you if you haven't been any palma
west of element it was pretty primitive
but we did not watch it not 68k we have
a really tiny garbage collector with the
garbage collector at the bank was about
15 kilobytes of code which in the old
days would be huge but we were pretty
proud to get it down to that and we were
actually the official GV
for Palm Pilot and ship the last few
years before they went under so if you
have a Palm Pilot I guess a model was
after the 5c but when they we were on 68
k and the arm versions for a couple
models so if you own one you may have my
BM on your 100th on fire the only 28
every reference year's topic I heard
this would be around two thousand three
it's like getting a I pocket no three
days ipod so maybe I 2001 I'm yeah yeah
song you know maybe going to be great my
message engine is that oh you poor
creature so Union google probably become
popular cansada Sophie about the project
yeah Michael's it's nice I'm remember
using altered esta I remember is going
downhill search for Jack alpha assembly
and the top pocket all pornography tells
you the same only the cigars before mom
packed all my stuff thank you very much
everybody